>> FINNE: Hello, everyone. Happy Thursday.
Welcome to the last Good I/O session in this
track and I think the last of all the sessions.
This is Analyzing and Monetizing your iPhone
apps. My name is Chrix Finne and I'm a product
manager on the mobile ads team at Google.
And this is my colleague Jim Kelm. We're here
to talk to today about AdWords, AdSense and
Google analytics for your apps. Just to get
started, out there today, how many folks use
Google AdWords today? Anybody? Got a few people,
awesome. How many use AdSense either on their
blog or whatever? Awesome. And how many people
are using Google analytics, websites? Look,
look at those, awesome. So, this maybe a little
review for some of you guys but we've got
some exciting stuff in store. And, yeah, that's
really about it. We have some T-shirts and
pamphlets for you at the end if you stick
around. So, I just wanted to throw that out
their. And we'll get started, this is Jim.
>> KELM: Well, thanks, Chrix. It's great;
a lot of you are already familiar with some
of the products that we'll be talking about
today. So, yeah, let's jump in. Before we
get started, I've always wanted something
like this for a lot of meetings that I'm in,
sort of the guide of this presentation or
how to get from now to happy hour. We're going
to talk a little bit about platform, that'll
be interesting. We're going to talk about
$100 free credit that you're getting. That
should be really interesting. Afterwards,
we're going to show a live implementation
of Google ads inside mobile applications.
That's going to be really special for me and
really amusing for you. And then Chrix is
going to talk some more about analytics. And
one of the disclaimer before we begin, we're
all developers here or used to be developers
and in case with me. And I'm used to engineering
slides having a certain histologic aspect
to them, but we're talking about monetization,
we're talking about business. And so, don't
hold the prettiness of the business slides
against them.
>> FINNE: So, fundamentally, we know that
you guys are all app developers but also,
you know, these apps are becoming businesses
in many folk's cases and so that's important
and we're trying to--trying to speak to that
too. So, there some very pretty slides. Thank
you to our colleague Lawrence to refer all
of our work by the way.
>> KELM: So let's talk a little bit about
the life cycle of an application. So it starts
with you have an idea, you bounce it off to
your friends, you start hacking your way at
it; before you knew it, you got an app. And
then you're--you're sitting their, you're
adding features to it, your debugging it,
you launch it, and you start to get users.
And it starts to grow and grow and grow and
you're getting up in the morning and seeing
how many downloads roll over night. And it's
really exciting stage. And then at some point,
you have enough users that you start to think
about monetizing this thing. And you've--in
a sense you've paid your app and now your
apps starts paying you. You put--you can put
some ads in it. Start to make revenue off
that way. And before it long, your app keeps
growing. Your phone might ring one day and
it's some agency or advertiser on the other
end and they want to directly buy some inventory
from you. All of a sudden, you've got this
robust business based on your application.
So the good news is Google can be there for
you all along the way. Starting with the Android
platform as a great place to build your apps,
to analytics for measuring and improving your
applications, to AdWords for promoting your
applications, driving that growth just a little
bit faster, AdSense for monetizing them, and
then later on when you start doing direct
sales, you can use double click for publishers,
in manager sales, in backflow with AdSense
or even third party on that works. We will
talk about all of those today. So let's start
with building your app. So, let's see, Chrix
you already asked about AdWords and AdSense.
Anyone who have an iPhone app out there? Okay,
a bunch of people. Anyone who have an Android
app? And for those of you who--all right,
yeah. For those of you who don't have Android
apps, a lot of you can--the remainders considering
building Android apps in the near future,
so yeah. So, you've got company. You know,
as Vic was saying this morning, Androids got
momentum. And, you know, it's a lot of people
are developing for it and even those that
haven't build apps for it or are planning
to develop them in the next six months. And
also as you heard this morning, you know,
Android devices are now shipping number two
in the U.S. market behind BlackBerry which
is incredible. So, there's a lot of momentum
here and it's a great place to build your
app. Now, you're already familiar with AdWords.
One can that we started to see out there is
developers using advertising in order to promote
their apps early in the life cycle. We all
know how important it is to achieve a certain
level of downloads is that you'll end up in
rankings in front of consumers and the sort
of organic--the burst of organic growth you
can have when get there. Fortunately, Google
knows a little bit about the online advertising
business. And we've taken this to mobile.
And there are some powerful capabilities we
can offer you. First is reach. So across all
of our ad networks, be they search or content,
we can reach consumers wherever--and users,
wherever you need to. Second is targeting.
So we've got some great ways to target ads
like carrier, by device, by location, and
all the ways that we traditionally do for
those who have ads.
>> FINNE: Things like, you know, placements
and keywords, obviously, all these things
we're all sort of fundamental.
>> KELM: And finally, they are the tools that
you needed in order to measure and monitor
your campaigns and track conversions so that
you know that your advertising is effective.
As I was saying, we can reach users on a number
of different networks. Earlier today, Vic
was talking about how different advertisers
have different needs when it comes to ad formats.
And you can use the different formats that
we've--and the different functions we've created
in order to reach users wherever they are
particularly when they're engaged in mobile.
So, for example, you can reach them in other
mobile applications, you can reach them when
you're browsing the Web, which we're hear
today. Despite rumors, on the contrary, it's
the number of three usage of the smartphones
behind the phone calls and text. And you can
reach someone you're doing mobile search.
So one particular example of this that we've
highlighted is the Corcoran Group, they are
a real estate company in New York. They built
an app in order to highlight their listings
to perspective the real estate purchasers.
And they wanted to drive adoptions as quickly
as possible. They used an AdWord campaign
and we're able to boost their downloads by
28% with a minimum investment, and so that
worked very well for them and its something
that's affordable to any app developer out
there.
>> FINNE: I kind of want to also just really
stress the importance of how we see application
advertising as one sort of route to bootstrapping
your app, you know, up into an apps store
because these apps stores have these ecosystems
around featured and top ex-apps. It can be
really important to kind of get into that
slot and you can use advertising as one way
to sort of bootstrap your way up there. This
sort of app ads are something that we're seeing
a lot more developers doing when we think
it's providing a lot of use list to them.
It's dead simple, you just link to the app
store in your ad, AdWords actually handles
all the targeting in our end and you can get
doing, you know, probably just after the session,
if you guys want to.
>> KELM: Great. So it worked for Corcoran
and we'd like to see it work for you which
is why we're providing $100 free advertising
credit to any Google I/O developers that has
signed up for AdSense for mobile applications.
So we would encourage you to use this $100,
create some ads; see if you can drive some
installs in your apps. And you can find out
more information about that on google.com/mobileads.
One important note, this supply is not only
the slides but also to ads when you're trying
to promote your applications, definitely putting
this mix credibility. Okay, earning from your
app. So you've got some scale, you've got
some users out there and just as publishers
monetize their traffic, you can monetize your
usage. So that's where this opportunity is
just growing everyday. It was under half a
billion dollars last year and it's going to
quadruple within the next couple of years.
And it's really just the beginning. What we're
seeing is large traditional advertisers are
only starting to experiment in mobile. And
largely they're finding what all of you already
know which is that the users are there and
that they're engaged. So we expect more and
more advertising by June to go in to mobile
advertising. And as we find new innovative
ad formats to engage users appropriately in
a mobile context, we expect the pie to just
continue to grow. To click to call ads that
we're showing this morning were one example
of them. These are testing incredibly well
with advertisers and they are proving to be
a significant source of revenue to our publishers.
So, that's where AdSense comes in. So AdSense
has enabled web publishers to monetize their
traffic and we have AdSense for mobile applications
now or AFMA as we sometimes you call it for
mobile app developers. Same concept as putting
ads in your website, put them in your mobile
application and start to earn money from your
applications. So this has been in private
data for a while now with a small number of
developers. As was announced this morning,
we're opening it up to all the Google I/O
attendees. And we look forward to your feedback.
So, what did--can AdSense for mobile applications
offer you? First, AdSense has a great fill
rate, you know, any ad network we'll talk
about, the revenue they can potentially provide.
But in order to do that they have to be able
to fill the inventory, to sell your inventory
to advertisers. AdSense offers that right
out of the--right from the start. Second is
our focus on user experience. So, in general,
the Google products were constantly focused
on the user and we're trying to iterate and
improve their experience with the product.
And I might say, "Well, what does that mean
in the context of ads." What it means in ads
is looking for new ways to match a user with
an ad out there that would be the most relevant
to them at this particular time or in this
particular context and were constantly investing
there. And those investments will yield improvements
in the user experience in the ads in your
application, because we want overtime to write
more and more relevant ads. And then finally,
we've got a great sales team. And they are
on the phone everyday with all of the agencies,
brand advertiser, direct advertisers, and
small and medium businesses out there. And
they'd be happy to help sell your inventory
too. So you saw this morning in Vic's keynote,
I think, seven or eight different new ad formats
that we've done, including expandable ads
which we think are great thing because they
enable users to interact with the ads without
leaving your application. You saw "click to
call" which is showing great traction with
a category of advertisers that is really eager
to get into it. And you even saw Google serving
third-party ads, rich media ads on our network.
And so those are some examples of innovative
ad formats that we've been rolling out. And
that we will continue to rollout across our
network.
>> FINNE: Yeah, really. This is really just
a beginning of a whole wave and you can see
this across the industry of really interesting
things that people are able to do with mobile
devices, right? You know user's location potentially.
You know various other things that you can
basically use to help deliver the most relevant
information. That's both for search and ads
and everything that we think about in Google
Mobile. And as those things progress, that
just brings sort of more value into the picture
for you guys as developers, for our users,
and for everyone which is really exciting.
It's really just the tip of the iceberg.
>> KELM: So now comes the demo. AdSense for
mobile application is really easy to implement.
So easy that even product managers maybe able
to do so onstage. So let's give it a shot.
So there's three key things here; it's basically
modify your layout to have an ad view. You
may need to change some permissions. This
is Android example, and a little bit of code
that you add. So let's get to it. All right.
Okay, so I said step one is modify your layout;
actually, step zero is make sure that you've
got the JAR to do. There's also one here for
Google Analytics that Chrix will be talking
about. All right, I'm in a--by the way this
is the code for the Google I/O, Android App,
which were going to be open sourcing if it
isn't already. Hopefully, some of you have
seen it. We're going to modify that to put
in an ad. So I've got the activity main XML
file open, and at the end we just put in little
ad view, pretty straightforward. Step two
was the permissions. So as was discussed in
the keynote today, we get--we want to enable
the Internet, which we have done, and may
already have--probably already have in your
applications. As a side note for Analytics,
we also want to enable access network state,
so pretty straightforward. Okay, then all
we need to do is do an import for AdSense.
I've done a couple others, so I don't get
some notifications. Analytics, same thing,
clear some strings, client ID, app name, the
company name, and keywords. And just create
an ad view here. Now we're going to do an
expandable ad, although it's going to be at
the bottom of the screen expanding up as opposed
to earlier today there was one at the top
of the screen expanding down. And then you
show it. So that's really just a few lines
of code. Let's go over into--I mean later,
okay. It's running. And that's all it takes
to put a Vampire Diaries' trailer ad in your
application. So...
>> FINNE: Nicely done, sir.
>> KELM: Okay, so again. All we had to do
there, it's so easy a PM could do it; was
modified the layout, permission for the Internet
if not--if you don't already have it, and
add a little bit of code. So how do I get
started? Well, if you don't already have an
AdSense account signup for it. And then once
your account is activated go in to AdSense.
Under the AdSense Setup tab, you'll find AdSense
for mobile applications, just select that.
And follow the steps to apply to the data.
When you're registered for Google I/O, you
got a Google I/O confirmation number. Use
that number in the process when we ask for
it because it'll enable us to identify you
as developers and give you a little bit of
extra attention to help you get onboard faster.
So as I said earlier, you know, some of you
are going have rising--you know, Rising Star
Applications that are just going to grow and
grow and grow, and those are always great.
And someday you may be approached by an agency
or an advertiser that wants to buy directly
from you. I just wanted to note that Google
does have tools to help you for that. That's
what double click for publishers was all about
on desktop, it was that we had these publishers
that reached to scale where they started doing
their own direct sales. And they needed to
be able to manage those sales. And then for
the inventory that they didn't sell, they
wanted to backfill it with AdSense or really
whichever network would pay them the most.
And that's what double click for publishers
was on desktop and we've extend that to mobile.
So Google can be there to grow with you as
your business needs for your apps grows. So
now I'm going to turn in over Chrix to talk
to you a little bit more about Analytics.
>> FINNE: Thanks so much, Jim. Get the thinger
here. Cool. So I guess--we've talked about
sort of all the things that you can do to
sort of turn your app into more of a business.
And, you know, whether or not you're even
using advertising in your application, you
really want to know what's going on. And I
hope that that's something that, you know,
that desire is shared. I mean this is something
that has become sort of a core part of the
Web ecosystem over the last 10 years that
you, you know, take some traffic, you know,
coming into a website or a mobile app or whatever
and, you know, sort of slice and dice it to
understand the types of things that your users
are doing and to get insights about what they
might want or might not be getting out of
your site or app or whatever. I mean that's
really what Google Analytics core mission
is all about. I've noticed that a lot of you
are already users on the Web, which is great.
So I apologize if some of this is background.
But as of November, we are actually offering
two SDKs for iPhone and Android apps to bring
that same sort of goodness straight into your
app. We know that most of your apps are connected
and, you know, are in many ways, you know,
similar to sort of, you know, Web applications
out there online. And by bringing Analytics
into your apps, you can start to get the same
sorts of insights and other, you know, optimizations
basically that you would used to online. One
thing that Analytics really does well and
that we're starting to bring to Android is
referral tracking. So, you know, say, you
actually are paying for traffic to your app
or you're linking to it from your website
or maybe you get a blog post. You really want
to know whether or not all those different
traffic sources are providing value, right?
Especially, if you're for paying them, right?
And we can start to do that. All right, this
is something that has been around not for
while on the web as I've said and is bringing--we're
bringing into apps. We're bringing the sorts
of insights and reporting that you need to
make sure you're users are getting what they
need out of your apps. I need to make sure
I didn't miss anything before we move along.
Yes, and then of course the last point is
that this is all part of Google Analytics
that many of you know and love already. Like
the interface is the same, you came to the
same front-end, and you can understand what
people are doing in your app in the same interface
even alongside the reports of what they may
doing--may be would be doing on your website,
which is just--is just really cool. So let's
take a look. This is actually our mobile devices
report that we added to Google Analytics again
when we launched back in November. This along
with the carrier report and what we call an
advance segment, it let's you look at your
mobile traffic in a little more, you know,
sort of mobile specific way. Obviously, most
people out there on the web wouldn't care
about your mobile device or your carrier,
but we know that people that are in mobile
do. So we can show you this, we can show you
what sorts of, you know, different types of
trafficking patterns they're getting, what
sorts of, you know, engagement and usage and
we can also split any of your mobile traffic.
Maybe you have a site that has both mobile
and regular desktop traffic. We can split
any of the Analytics reports by mobile using
this advance segment, which is pretty cool,
not really relevant to apps but it's also
really cool. So, using these sorts of reports
you can understand what people are doing with
mobile but this is just a tiny, I think, maybe
2% or 3% subset of all the different reports
that are available in Google Analytics that
you understand really anything you can imagine
about your users. I'm not going to have time
to go through them all today, but, you know,
again the basic idea is that we're bringing
all of this power from Google Analytics out
there on the Web straight into apps. So let's
talk a little bit more about exactly what
we can do in Google analytics form mobile
apps. So as I've mentioned the basic, basic
thing is aggregate usage tracking. We have
sort of borrowed the concept of the pageview,
which is, again, you know, very sort of fundamental
metric out there on the Web. How many page
users you're getting a day? How many unique
visitors divided by page user hopping? All
of these sorts of things and brought it straight
into your app. It's trivially easy. I'll show
you in a second to trigger a pageview whenever
you sort of load a new screen or a new level
or whatever it may be in your app and, you
know, compare to that to the other pages.
You can start to get metrics like, you know,
number of unique users in seven days, time
on site, time between different page users.
You can start to see where people are really
engaging with your app and where they may
not be. And that can lead to like really,
really interesting insights. As I was mentioning,
you can sort of start to slice these engagement
metrics. Again, all based on sort of that
atom of the pageview into all sorts of different
things. So you can--you can talk about session
length, you can talk about, you know, things
like whether or not a user, you know, bounces
at one page versus another or whether maybe
they come back and bounce or if they're returning.
There's a bunch of different ways of slicing
that. And again this is all just coming straight
into the apps with very, very, very little
effort on you guys' part. It really is just
the equivalent of dropping that Google Analytic
JavaScripts, dip it into any website, which
I guess many of you already are familiar with.
As I've mentioned before we have a few sort
of mobile extras, such as device and carrier
reporting as well as this mobile segment.
It's sort of let's you look at any traffic.
Maybe you actually want to put all of your
traffic into one analytics report. I--I know
many people out there have apps that are actually
very similar to a website out there. So, you
could actually line them up against each other
and compare to see, say, if somebody is maybe
engaging more with the sort of appefied version
of your service versus the Web version. I
know this is certainly true when you look
at a lot of the big players out there like
eBay. They have both a really great mobile
website and a really great mobile app. I'm
a big fan and, you know, if I were them, I
would want to know whether or not these two
sorts of similarly featured platforms are--are
performing similarly or not. There's one other
thing in the analytics sort of world that's
a little less well-known, that we think is
really exciting especially for sort of the
application use case, and that's called event
tracking. I'm going to show you also how to
set that up in a minute, but, basically, sort
of separate from this sort of basic pageview
base reporting. Analytics offers a flexible
framework to just declare events, like something
happened, right? And they can, you know, you
can name them anything, they will actually
have three different levels of hierarchy that
you can group them into. So, you can have
in all the buttons in your app or a group
and maybe the different labels and the different
sort of actions on those different buttons.
And you can start to understand how often
these things are occurring basically and how
much value they're bringing you, which is--which
is pretty neat. You could imagine a scenario
where you're a gamer or something, all right.
And you could actually, you know, trigger
an event every time somebody kills a monster,
right? Okay, so that's something. But maybe
you have a bunch of different monsters in
your game that you want to try and tune. So
you could just trigger an event and then understand
how many monsters are actually being successfully
killed by your users and tune them that way.
I know they're like the World of Warcraft
guys do this all the time by turning the knobs.
So these are the sorts of insights you can
start to get. Really it's pretty neat to be
able to sort of not worry about this. There's
a lot of, you know, in theory any of this
can be done on you guys as in these developers,
if you log and send stuff back, but we sort
of we're able to do this at scale and provide
reports for you just really easily. And this
is all made possible by sort of this intelligent
SDK. Again, it's trivially easy to implement
as you'll see in a minute, but what the SDK
allows you to not worry about are things like
network and battery. Things that, you know,
actually are important considerations when
you're building your mobile app. You don't
want to run down the user's battery. You don't
want to hang the app. Well, you should never
put it in the main thread, but you don't want
to hang the app if the network is down or
any things like this. And so no matter how
many events in the pageviews or whatever else
is going on that you're sending to our Analytics
SDK, it's going to intelligently batch those
and sort of hang on to them until either set
dispatch interval hits, you know, every minute
or two or whatever, or until your app has
some other sort of network activity that goes
on and then all you need to do is call the
dispatch method and say, "All right, time
to phone home and send those events back to
Google Analytics." So it's actually pretty
flexible and we found that our developers
that who've adopted this so far have not really
seen any impact on battery life or anything
like that. So it's really pretty neat to be
able to sort of get this, you know, pretty
much for free. So that's all well and good
but, you know, why even do we offer Google
analytics for free, if you may ask. It's because
of what you can do when you're using it with
ads. This is again something that if you use
AdWords online, I hope you actually have it
hooked up to your Analytics account. But as
I was saying before, tracking referrals into
your app is a really powerful thing. And this
is something that is now possible using the
Android market in Google Analytics. So this
is something that is honestly the reason that
we provide it to the world, because it's so
valuable for our AdWords advertisers to be
able to see what traffic has coming in based
on different campaigns, different keywords,
you know, search engines versus direct traffic,
you know, links on blogs versus some, you
know, new sites or whatever else. Once you
see all those referrals coming in the different
traffic sources, you can split them and understand,
"Well, hey, you know, I did this campaign
but nobody convert it or I did other keyword
and everybody stayed on my site twice as long
as I thought they would." These are the sorts
of things you can start to understand in your
app. So let me talk a little bit more about
this funnel. Funnel is the sort of, you know,
sales speak for this, sorry, but, anyway,
basically, let's just imagine you have an
app that you're trying to bootstrap and you
setup an ad campaign that say, "Hey, come
down to my app." And you have a couple of
different keywords there. So what you can
do now is just make a special Android Marketplace
URL for that. It's pretty easy, you just append
the, you know, referral equals parameter,
because it doesn't really work like it would
on the web in the HTTP header. And you say
this is this campaign, this is this other
one. So users go and start clicking on those
links and it, you know, sends them to the
Android Market download page, right? So they
say, "Okay, do I want this? Do I not want
this?" And the Android market now has an Android
1.6. back in November, is smart enough to
take that referral string and pass it as an
intent into the app. I think you guys have
all heard a lot about Android intents, if
you've been to the sessions today. We're using
that as well, so that any app that's getting
installed from some link that came from one
of these referral strings gets that into its
manifest and you can look at it. And our Analytics
SDK, once the user has sort of downloaded
and open the app, will automatically pick
that up and send that back as a traffic source
which is just really cool and it's open. And
this referral technology is something that
anybody can use in their app. You don't have
to even be using the Google Analytics SDK,
you just sort of look out for it and you can
process that on your end if you want to. So
even, you know, other analytics providers
or whoever else can sort of use this Android
market pass through to get that sort of granular,
referral level of reporting on your user base,
which is just--which is just really exciting.
This is something that we're not--not aware
of any other sort of mobile app stores other
than the Android market offered today. And
there are--there are some other solutions
out there that do sort of--a little hacky
thing where they look at the device ID on
one end and then the other end to see if click
came from another application. But this is
really direct and pretty exciting because
we think that this is making that sort of
value that people are used to on the Web available
on people's apps. So this is great. There's
one other pretty neat thing that we're actually
just about to release out into the wild which
is AdSenses. As Jim mentioned you guys are
all welcome to sign up for AdSense for mobile
apps and apply for that today. And so once
that starts going, you want to know about
that too. As about a year ago, we actually
provide an AdSense integration into ad analytics
on the web and we're adding that to mobile
apps now too. So what you can see here is
a report which starts to tell you which pages,
which of use of your app are monetizing well
or are not. So that's really important, you
don't want to just know once you started running
ads in your app what the top line is, you
want to know, "Well, are my users getting
value from my ads or are they getting value
from the ads in all the different parts of
my application where there may be ads, or
the ads put in the right spot in the application
to sort of deliver the most value and the
most clicks from users because they click
when they think the ad is useful?" Do they,
you know, do--the users that are coming in
through this different referral channels,
they click on my ads or not? These are all
the sorts of insights that you can start to
get with this AdSense report. This is not
yet part of the public Google Analytics SDK
just because AdSense for mobile apps isn't
yet public. But once you're signed up and
running, you can ask for this from your Google
contact and we'll send it right along. So
that's pretty exciting. So what you need to
do to is just sign up. As I've mentioned several
times, it really is trivially easy; again,
so easy, a product manger can do it. So, we're
going to go through that right now. You just
go to google.com/analytics. You can sign up
for what's called the web property ID. You
probably already have one of these. If you
have it for your website, we recommend that
you create a separate sort of sub-property
for your app, but if you want to sort of correlate
them together, you can; you can even name
the page and use the same thing. It will actually
add together if you have sort of one to one
mappings of stuff in your app to stuff on
your website which is neat. You just import
our tracking SDK as very similar to what we
did with AdSense, and then you, you know,
send a few function calls out to track your
pages in event. So, let's see what that looks
like. We should shut down the thing here first,
okay. There it goes, cool. So, again, I'm
just going to go back and check my build path
here. As you can see, we have the "libgoogleanalytics.char"
which is right there and that's available
for download today, if you'd like. And then
we back--we go back to Android manifest and
just verify-- set this up just before hand
so I wouldn't make any typos, but we have,
you know, access to the Internet so we can
send those sort of batches that hits home,
and we have this sort of network state here.
What that's allowing the app to do--sorry--allowing
the Analytics SDK to do inside of your app
is look at those HTTP requests, and when you
want, piggy back on them before they get closed.
So if you call the dispatch method, it just--it'll
just sort of hop in there and then you don't
get any access network or battery overhead
which is really cool. And lets go look at
what it looks like in the--it will avoid main
here. So, here we are. So, Google Analytics
tracker is the library that we're importing,
that's really all you have to do. As you can
see at the beginning of our activity here,
we've instantiated a tracker object, which
we call a tracker. So there's the instantiation
of that. And then to call our first pageview,
all we need to do is, say, "tracker.start,"
we put in that Web property ID that you would
have gotten signing up online. And I've put
in 20 seconds here so that's the default dispatch
interval, as you leave that parameter out
it will wait until you call the dispatch method
on your piggy backing. But for this app, we're
just going to send a message every 20 seconds
or--however, many have spool up in that time,
and then we just say track page you, it's
really that easy. We're calling this page
the Google I/O home screen page but, you know,
you can of course create a hierarchy just
as you would with a website and the network's
just the same; so that's pretty neat. And
so what about events? As you can see we have
and event down there, but I had a few buttons
in that app if you remember up in the front,
if you've used the app. What do you have to
do with a sort of maybe instrument one of
these buttons? So let's go back to our layout
here, go find some of the buttons, where are
the buttons? Here we go. So here's the scheduled
button, here's the map button. I already have
the scheduled buttons set up so let's set
up the map button. All I need to do is create
an on-click method for the button. This is
probably something you should have for your
button already, I guess, but we don't in this
case. So, we're going to call it on map click,
so that's good to go there. And then I just
go back here and we're going to create the
on map click method. Good to do down here.
It should look pretty similar in the schedule
one. And we're just going to say, "tracker.trackeven".
These again are those three levels of hierarchy
that I was mentioning before. This is going
to be a click event for a button and we're
going to call this the map button. So you're
going to also assign a value to any event
which is, again, if you actually have transactions
happening, it's pretty neat because it will
sort of add them all up and you can compare
them by the different sort of categories of
events which are driving more or fewer sort
of dollars or points or whatever they are
in your app. So, I think that is all good
to go, don't forget the semicolon, and let's
see what happens. Okay, we'll save, just a
second. We'll go back to our emulator, and
here it comes. So there we go, we got a second
ad impression which is great. I can just go
in here and button mash on my little buttons
here, and those are now going to start sort
of triggering these events and sending them
back up to Google Analytics. So, that's really
all there is to it. So let's see what this
actually looks like. Go back to Google Analytics
here. I'm going to log in to my demo account,
so I have to sort of do the Julia Child thing
here. Those clicks I just made aren't going
to show up for a few hours, so I did a few
yesterday to see if all the caps rollout.
So here we go. So there we go. Look at that.
Just yesterday we had a bunch of visits and
we can sort of zoom in on that. Awesome slide.
There we go. So we had five visits yesterday,
we've had 11 visits today, and it's really
easy to sort of see what's happening. As you
can see, all of my traffic here is direct
traffic, because we've just been coming straight
to the app from that emulator. But if I were
to push those apps out to the Android market,
you can start to see those sorts of referral
track or, you know, splits right here in your
traffic sources which is pretty neat. As you
can see, today we only have the one page in
our little silly demo app, but, you know,
we've got 60 unique views on that page in
the last day and 50% bounce rate, that's so
great. But you can, you know, start to dig
in with all of these things in, you know,
just a plethora of report the Analytics offers.
So what happen with events? Oh, there's events.
I can also just get a really easy roll up
of the events that have occurred. We actually
had 46 yesterday and 20 today so far which
is, you know, exciting, though I don't know
if I like the slope of that graph. I can look
in here and you can see the all 66 of those
events were actually, you know, part of a
button which is intended and we can go down
and just break it down by the schedule map
in sessions button you can see, you know,
how many events were triggered? How many events
were unique per event type? And, you know,
how much value you're going getting. You can
see that the schedule button is actually driving
a lot more value than the map one in this
case. So, whatever, you know, value you may
ascertain from your app, you can start to
understand that using events. It's very flexible
and a great way to sort of get those sort
of second order insights into what people
are actually doing rather than just looking
at your pages which is really cool. And, you
know, that's really about it, the Analytics
SDK is very easy to get going, you just go
to code.google.com/mobileanalytics/api/mobileanalytics.
Excuse me, and we have all of what I've shown
you today documented so you can get set it
right up. So, let's go back to the presentation.
And yeah, that's actually all there is to
it, google.com/mobileads. I think you've guys
have seen a lot today, that's where you can
get signed up fro ad words, or Adsense for
mobile apps. There is a sort of approval process
for AdSense accounts just because we will
end up, you know, paying you guys money, so
hope you can understand that. And the same
thing for AdWords if you want to get set up,
you just sort of enter into the account sign
up process and it's very easy. Analytics is
even easier, you just go to code.google.com/api/mobileanalytics
and you can download the SDKs for iPhone or
Android today. Jim and I are going to be hanging
around after the presentation; I think it
might be time for some T-shirts.
>> KELM: Yeah, we've got T-shirts in the back.
We've also got flyers.
>> FINNE: This is our colleague Loren right
by the back left back door who has T-shirts
and flyers if you're interested in signing
up for AdSense. We thought we'd end a little
bit early today because it is the end of the
session and you guys are obviously eager for
happy hours. So thank you so much, and have
a great trip home those of you who had made
it out here.
>> KELM: Thanks everyone.